Eric is on the line and he's in Florida
hi Eric welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey how you doing better than I deserve
what's up hey yeah I just found you on
YouTube about past year or so started
learning about your baby steps in
session I'm actually really excited to
start paying off my own debt but I got a
question about my sister and 20 I moved
in with her to help with living costs
while she's in doctorate school but
she's horrible with money and she's
currently only using student loans to
pay for everything but she blows them
within like a couple months of
disbursement so with our new lease I had
a bright idea to charge her twenty four
eight twenty four percent APR interest
on like any back rent that she may owe
me but I'm really afraid that I'm
robbing her of her own future if I do
this so I guess the question is like do
you think I'm doing the right thing to
protect myself and help further my own
baby steps or should I approach this in
a different manner you live in her house
no we have a lease together with one of
her roommates or whatever college
classmates okay we who's we you and her
and the college roommate yeah there's
three of you originally it was just me
and her in a smaller house but then to
help me because she owed me so much in
rent we brought in one of her classmates
as a third roommate so where I'm
supposed to be paying so you've been
paying their rent are you on the lease
yeah I am yes okay for how much longer
um it's for another year and a half
why did you sign a multi-year lease uh
mainly because I hate moving I so I know
that you know I find it with the
assumption that she was not going to pay
me the entire time I thought that
charging her interest would be enough
motivation to get me right on time but
it's already not working out with that
so I I'm not a what do you what are you
what do you make a year I actually I
have a very decent salary I think about
seventy-five thousand here okay and
she's in school yeah okay and how much
is the rent rent right now is nineteen
forty five is what it's averaging with
that utilities and such Wow
that's a lot for you to be paying making
seventy five by yourself yeah it is it's
really slowed me down on debt repayments
but thankfully how much is the other
roommates supposed to pay and do they
pay yes thankfully um I know it's
horrible of me but I know that she has
parents backing her up with her college
degree so I know that her money should
be coming in throughout the entire lease
why is that horrible of you uh I do have
a tenant that you have a tenant that is
well-heeled and gonna pay the bill well
it's my sister her thirty two bill I'm
having does I understand I understand
but the other roommate there's nothing
horrible about the fact that you have a
good one oh yeah I'm sorry yeah okay now
as far as your sister goes there's a
good rule of thumb on all ethics
questions and that is treat other people
like you would want to be treated so
let's just reverse it for a minute
you're horrible with money and your
sister moves you in to help you to tell
help her save money and then you don't
pay the bill okay mm-hmm so just walk
around in her moccasins for a minute
here what is best for her is what we're
asking and what's best for her is
obviously to stop living like a doofus
right right for her to get her crap
together that's what's best for her you
to charger twenty four percent is not
what's best for her that's not what
motivates her you take over all of her
bill paying and handle her checking
account as if she had
is a mentally incapacitated would might
be best for her until she can start
acting like a freaking adult now that'd
be okay
and I might do that might be best for
her if she was out on her own and didn't
live there anymore but it's not best for
her for her own brother to charge her
twenty four percent interest
agreed I agree yeah in other words would
you want someone that what would you
want someone to do with you if you were
a money doofus you were horrible like
she is and you know you'd want some help
you know and granted she has to make the
decision to be a grown-up and make some
you know you use her brain and actually
make some positive decisions but you
know I'd want someone to come alongside
me coach me pat me on the back kicked me
in the butt coach me Pat me on the back
kicked me in the butt until I got my act
together I'd want someone to love me
that much and that's much more difficult
than just standing back and going you're
an idiot and I'm gonna charge you 24
percent no I understand how you got
there I don't blame you for getting
there but you know sometimes it's harder
to it takes more energy to love people
well does that make sense yeah and so I
would I would put some real ultimatums
in her life
24 percent is no longer an option I
refuse to take advantage of you or
anyone else in my future because I'm
going to treat other people like I want
to be treated so here's what I Monday
I'm going to get deeply involved in your
finances and I'm going to help you
handle them as if you were mentally
incapacitated until you prove otherwise
or if you do not relinquish that to me
you're moving you have to leave because
I'm not going to participate in you
misbehaving in your life and bringing
harm to your life and me supporting your
crazy by paying your rent because you're
being crazy and so a confrontation is
inevitable here because that's what a
loving person would do with her and
apparently what your parents didn't do
they let her get away with murder she
was daddy's little princess or so
and what am I missing
yeah I would never say that to their
faces but yeah okay I mean I'm some how
she got here
I'm making that up I don't know but I'm
just I'm reading the tea leaves here and
saying what really happened to cause
this young woman to get to the point
that she is completely oblivious to the
fact that she has to pay bills I mean
that's pretty that's pretty princess
oriented so you just you know you're a
little brother big brother big brother
good good well big brother put your arm
around your little sister and kick her
butt love her and kick her butt love her
and kick her butt and take over her life
and guide her into adulthood but there's
it's not motivating her to charge her 24
percent it's not motivating her drag her
butt to Financial Peace University make
her go to class make her go to one of
the events we're having in Florida this
year you want to do that we'll be in
Orlando doing an event I'll give you a
couple tickets if you're in that area
hold on now I have kelly pick up but
let's help this girl get her life turned
around because she's incapacitated she's
not living in adult life